das ist toll dass so viele kerne rheine
sind so viele kerne richtig darum ringen
als zugabe
los gehts und herzlich willkommen zur
zweiten folge von handicap games ich
sage euch so viel
heute wird es richtig schmerzhaft heute
wird es richtig scharf heute ist richtig
scharf und schmerzhaft denn ich hab mir
manchmal kann man das sehen dass hier
geholt wo man ja okay ist um madonnas
geholt ich überhaupt nicht ich hab mir
die disco leute und wir spielen heute
mit folgendem handicap jedes mal wenn
ich sterbe muss ich ein groß sind und
wirklich großen wissen von chili nehmen
und die chinesen brutal aber dazu oft
nicht mehr
ich würde sagen dass das will ich mehr
es hat unzählige challenge und jedes mal
wenn ich jemanden töten
da habe ich hier von von diesem
magerquark einen löffel nehmen weil es
birgt ich hoffe es wird irgendwie
beruhigend für den hals deutlich abgeben
mit der lippe nur mit der definitiven
gerührten es wird sich anders dar
eingeschnittenen messer eltern aber
macht ein dummes ding aus jetzt macht es
aus
bild erstellt youtuber schild ich
gemeint sein glaub ich das zum 4 2
wie gesagt wenn ich sterbe komme ich zum
betteln reinbeißen
ich habe hier schon mal probiert
höllisch scharf das übel das ist richtig
richtig übel
ich finde nicht dass das ein cooles
konzept ist was wir überlegt was man mit
der challenge sache cola den sp in die
kommentare schreiben
er ist cool findet das letzte video mit
den zwei kammern fest geben kann ja
vielleicht recht schicken
das hat mir auch mega gut gefallen ein
gewählte [ __ ] beste bild okay gut
gefällt dann eigentlich okay wir machen
natürlich an mehreren sonst könnte ja
stimmt ja wahrscheinlich schon alle ein
zwei drei vier fünf
und ich bin übrigens devil georgen ein
gotteshaus ist schon richtig scheißhaus
wenig darum zum lama sie kommt nämlich
nur fünf geben
ich sagte mir ist es egal ich trenne
40er zeit weg mir ist mir egal also
bevor ich verrecke dass mir die kiste da
du blöder ich bin devil gerne laufen
dann muss ich lauf nein nein
wie kann man das verpacken auf jeden
fall nicht aber ich darf nicht auch
nicht in städten
na klar dass sich verstecken weil das
ist positiv sagt noch niemand geht und
er ist du hast du hast schon mal was gut
ich das jetzt noch nicht eindeutig sagen
noch eingekeilt ich habe zwei gut ich
hab zwei gut ich hab zwei gut okay also
ich hab zwei dürfen war gut falls sie
jetzt gleich sterben
nein nein nein na ja und zwar bei der
boxen kommt im kontext von mir
bitte bitte bitte sie wissen ich weiß
dass für mich bedeutet ich muss meine
sprinters da hängt warum noch jemand
vater warum jetzt auf gott kommt es war
ein richtiger oder sind drei leute ich
bin tot ist dreierteam wie einst nur ein
häufig gewählt okay ich hab auch ein
habe ich drei läufe gut jetzt weil die
kannst du gut gebrauchen
der schuttberg man gott ich weiß solo
live was laut dge elektroschock
dreierteam was für aber okay leute es
ist soweit in die schon angesprochene
beißen weil dies richtig hart da will
ich direkt bei den ganzen kerl oder die
noch nicht angebrochen
die mit schonfrist von einem nicht
angeordnet
okay leute
das klingt jetzt ein bisschen rum spülen
in deinem monster bisschen klingt spitze
egal ob es kommt es kommt es kommt es
kommt es kommt es kommt es kommt ein
horror
aber der anfang an den start ich muss da
noch als nehmen das warten das war nicht
so hart für noch mehr leute noch mehr
seht es ja so viel
nein ich kann die kenne gar nichts mache
sechs bitte nein die karte ist super
easy altes gesetz zu kurze müssen kleine
karten spielen das so oft stirbst den
schmerz zweiter ist es die direkten
heißt es will halt direkt mitte
da sind richtig viele kisten nehmen
nicht die kiste unter derweil die sind
also bild und gehen als erstes an die
kiste unter sich dass das so alles für
dich in der mitte schon wieder mit
greifarm nicht mehr reden heute die wan
gang seit gar keinen bock auf uns als
das level gangster liefern leute reden
zuschauer sowie alter online.de starten
die hätte ich gesagt ich werde dich
zerbersten was man nach meinem entgehen
ok ich hab' schon ich habe schon gut da
ich habe schon gut dass es direkt in die
wand snacken alter dem basta
wo bist du willst du draußen draußen was
brennt
ich habe keine ahnung wo du bist
ich konnte konstant zurückkehrten
komplette komm her was machst du die
leute das ist die hölle alter oh mein
gott
wirst du das erste wenige aber ich habe
jetzt noch zwei dafür gut einer stunde
als chelsea kommt
da sind so viele leute war ok hab noch
drei löffel dafür
ich hole mir da keinen pass kurz auf
passaus geburt ok jetzt ist gerade wir
gerade jetzt wieder ist der klassiker
okay da kommt einer wusste da ist einer
wenn wir den ganz hohen bogen ist ja ich
nehme meine ich muss kämpfen wollten die
das wirst du denn von dem kind stil
halten dass mir den kick
okay okay ich habe erst mal eine waffe
ich habe 32
oh mein gott was habe ich will
chorleiter mit dem vollmond räte oder
ich mach den ich habe halbes leben auch
scheiß drauf
die gamescom 21 die ich mir ja keiner
dass meine gibson schon gut weil es
brennt so alter von einem tage davon ist
davon ist dieser typ längste krieg jetzt
so auf die schnauze
der wollte ich enthalten dass der böse
zurückgehen der track die sie direkt
okay ich habe mein chef verdient hatte
hier hat meine schwester hatte wer so
etwas macht sorry aber operativ bisschen
allein [ __ ]
ich mache ich koche emsland wo an was
wann hast du ja okay okay aber ich
kann's mir vollkommen egal sein aber du
wirst du von anstrengen damit ich leide
entscheidet allein gott ich kann ich den
garten so langsam wieder unter den
lebenden alles klar
ich habe keine zeit ich brauche keine
ikone vierten stil
nein
johann avandia schwert und relaxt mit
alex bei mir du bist geburt hat sich
folge vorsätzlich so gekühlt damit
douglas adams geburt wie du dich durch
gekettet ist leider gar keine
fernkampfwaffen es sind ein schnauze
liga naja okay es geht weiter leute raus
in die lobby und ich musste das ist
einfach das ist die hölle bei dessen so
viele kerne sich umbringen
sogar 74 30 37 immer der schluckauf
leute ganz scharf ist krieg so schlosser
aus einer verbesserten weil es ein super
große karte ist rechts dann wir treffen
uns nichts an
ich heiße sie von rechts an die rechner
okay ich hab natürlich vom marktplatz
gut weiß was ihr euch danke
auch verdammt in technologie sie
kreischen können auch mal zu wissen noch
am start hinter der spd ist eine hintere
ist ein bisschen amlin alter ja schön
wenn wir eine weise entscheidung
gewinnen lassen können aber es brennt so
alt dass brands so widerwärtig
ich darf mich wenn es ganz schlimm ist
dann käme hier einfach links hier im
haus ist einer der sockel noch lebe ich
noch lebe ich warte ich gehe ich folge
bislang hatte kraft
jawohl ich hatte ich bin ich bin froh
nicht holt mit ihrer aktion hätte ist
der stau ist so gut ausgerüstet
honico hat stets gegeben hab das
fräulein wunder oder kommentiert wurde
ich brauche es die leute hier beachtet
dann kommst du also langsam lebe ich
will also ich würd sagen wir wiederholen
was das wort match ist dann kriegst du
dich fertig weiß was auf dem spiel steht
mein leben es wäre sogar eigentlich
möglich eine hier in inzell games zu
meinen zumindest sg sieben sich ein
scharfes 24 schwer zu machen
ich komme wenn der mitarbeiter ist ein
kleiner fns personelle missgeburt das
erste trikot ist der alte schneidet in
wicker wo ist das kabarett ausgelaufener
88 und ethik wiederbelebten ich warte ja
flexibel
warum ist es so aus am 27 28 das waren 1
2 verkürzt der zauber ist ein schritt
die verzauberten schwerte ich will hier
in rheine hat mich dann hat mich die
hätten sich gegenseitig die idioten
du hast auch wenn es noch ja sehr gut
sehr gut wenn du denn einer verbrennen
dann kannst du dir ein bisschen been
nice einer krieg auf den amboss ist
nicht schwer hatte sowas nicht gefixt
alter wertvoll viel abstand zu dem acht
junge der feinde gehen euch darauf wieso
du so bist du soleil fms fms sehr schön
kommt hast du du schaffst es alter was
für ein spannender kampf scheiße jetzt
ein halbes jahrzehnt dastehen gerüstet
auch schnell dass dessen chef von denen
aus der warte warte ich hab das gar
nicht aufkommen
ich muss erstmal nicht aufgehoben ist
als porno typ steht hier liegt glaube
ich noch hatte das ist auch heute noch
ein erfolg stan nicht gereicht du bist
allein nächst leben noch lebt noch ein
anderer geht euch drauf haut platzt die
kämpfen hatte das sieht was auch noch in
einem guten ich glaube schon okay der
eine brennt auch einfach applus die
beiden kämpfen und jetzt auch noch ein
killer
gut dass auf jeden fall die letzte runde
nein gott alter das war so schmerzhaft
leute das was schmerzhaft doch ich muss
immer noch einen guten 3 löffler ist gut
aufgenommen ich musste mir zusammen
hatten
wenn euch die gleich gefallen hat das
handicap dass einen glauben nach oben da
schreibt in die kommentare des niqab ihr
als nächstes sehen wollt ihr wisst
bescheid
max könnt ihr auch am tatmesser
beschreibung wenn sie mal zum nächsten
video wieder haut rein und zu hoch